- just complain about the loopy soupy
not expected settling exactly what I
predicted liquid lambshank
may be a step too far for my guess so I
hope Alexei's amazingly sophisticated
main courses are going to impress he's
working his ass off to make the soy and
honey marinated lamb spiced with chilies
and an extravagant lobster dish scented
with crisp curry leaves and cooked with
lemon chili and shelah front-of-house is
getting in a muddle
nothing seems to be coming out together
we can't keep a table hanging for seven
minutes without anything else arriving
on a day like today that's what I'm
trying to say okay okay
call the weather may cause event finish
the starters John send a starter and
they're ten seconds later send the main
course can you so my question originally
was who pulled away the main courses a
mock gala just we have Alex is it always
this crazy days of NBC our housing
service yeah watch out is fine with 15
which at the same time it's such a mess
that one diners dish the lamb have been
missed all together I'm hoping it's
gonna arrive recently soon because I'm
very very hungry okay from Michigan star
restaurant this is unforgivable
even worse burn of the owner is busy
serving up excuses to free staffs
cock-ups normally a meal here everything
is in the middle of the table so
everybody sharing this is unusually
today we've had to serve everything
individually
the share of startups fiber the author
of main course I think that customer
deserves it
the fact they took the order down and
incorrectly from the customers fault so
we should be telling them that I'd
rather just sort of hand in the deal
with it and move on okay my apologies
once the food arrives
most of my diners are blown away by
Alex's amazing dishes it is fantastic
the the Lambs tender is just wonderful
it was absolutely fantastic I've never
had lobster that's been pried before it
was really nice contrast as well as
having the strawberries and the grapes
and their amazing end of service and
time to tell Kai what I thought the
customers that did get the food on time
love the food it's quirky and it's very
striking when it hits all those notes
but we have to remember that when
customers come in for the first time
you've got to hold their hand every step
of the way that's where we've got to
work on yeah just got to keep working
keep joking working making a little bit
better every single suitable but I know
you can go further because you've done
it with the food and you can do it with
the service as well hit all those notes
there put them together bang you have an
amazing restaurant